Bad Bunny getting sued by his
ex-girlfriend for 40 million dollars
carlis De La Cruz Hernandez says that's
her voice in the Singer's party and now
she wants Benito to pay up De La Cruz
filed a lawsuit over the recording
earlier this month saying her ex used it
without her permission she alleges her
voice has now become a famous phrase
in addition to pothy the phrase is also
featured in 2022's dose meal 16. baby
I always
put my my a piece of my heart on
everything that I do Carles who dated
Bad Bunny on and off from 2011 to 2017
claims that his representative contacted
her last May and offered two thousand
dollars for the rights to the recording
but she turned it down
ET has reached out to bad Bunny's Reps
for common
meanwhile bat Bunny's got a new lady
love in his life Kendall Jenner I'm a
good guy
I'm cute
earlier this month the source told E.T
that Kenny's doing great since her
breakup with basketball player Devin
Booker last year and now she's focusing
on herself work family and friends and
enjoying her time with Bad Bunny it's
really exciting the Grammy winners also
fresh off a long-term relationship he
had been dating Gabriella Berlin Gary on
and off since 2017.
[Music]
another source says Kendall and Bad
Bunny are attracted to each other and
definitely have a flirty Vibe it's still
new but they're enjoying each other's
company and like each other however bad
a bunny is yeah so it's still cute
that's me
[Music]